aaron is with us in denver hi erin
welcome to the ramsey show
thank you sir for having me um long time
listener
uh you've helped me get through a lot of
stuff in the past and hopefully you can
help with situation now thanks how can i
help today
yeah uh so 30 years old me and my wife
we're looking at selling uh our houses
you know the market here in denver it's
pretty crazy
um we've got some pretty solid equity in
the house we have currently upwards of
300 000
i'm looking to buy a new house and we're
given a couple
options um from the lender that we're
working with and one of them i'm
extremely unfamiliar with i've owned
several houses traditionally done just a
fixed
interest mortgage they're offering me
what's called an
all-in-one loan and i just was curious
have you ever heard of that
good bad situation what what do you have
to say
i've not heard of it it does sound like
a brand particular to that
lender what does it entail
so how they're marketing it is it's
basically a savings account
that the balance in the account reduces
the interest
by that amount so you know we have about
fifty thousand dollars in cash that we
keep in the account at all times so
that would basically reduce the interest
that's charged on the account
the thing i don't like about it is it's
a variable interest rate right now it's
around three and a half
you know versus i can get a 1.99 on a
15-year
fixed um but it has potential to go up
from there it's kind of a sliding rate
so
um the math you know they provided me a
spreadsheet that said it'll save fifty
thousand dollars over the life and loan
or something you know something like
that but
um it's just kind of a new territory to
me yeah
if you put the 50 000 as an extra down
payment on the house
and you get out of debt that much faster
you're gonna make save a lot more than
their spreadsheet gave you
that's what i figured i'm an engineer so
i'm pretty good with math and i've tried
to
run a bunch of different scenarios and
end up being awash basically and here's
the other thing
here's the other part of that is there's
there's a part of the math that's hard
to put
in there and it's the analysis of risk
that the more debt you have on the house
obviously the higher your payment is and
so the more risk you have the longer
you're in debt
the more risk you have and the higher
the ratio of loan to value is
the higher your risk is uh and that that
it's hard to put
that to an actual math figure but that's
common sense we know that to be true
because you and i have walking around
since right we know that if i owe more
money i have more risk
duh you know so uh but but it's hard to
actually put an
actual dollar figure to that the way we
do see that play out in reality
and where we can measure it is like when
we did the the ramsey team did our
ramsey research study on millionaires
and we studied 10 000 millionaires
we didn't find a single one that used a
technique like you're talking about to
become wealthy not one
correct instead we found the typical
millionaire all the data tells us
that the typical millionaire quickly
gets out of debt average pays off their
home in 11.2 years
which means that some do it sooner some
do it longer but that was the average
among the 10
000 millionaires none of them were
sitting around going i'm going to figure
out a way
mathematically to borrow my own money
back and pay a little higher interest
rate on a variable
and spreadsheet says and you know all
this crap that they're telling you right
with this product so this product stinks
to high heaven dude run from it
bottom line you knew it you could feel
it in your bones but you hadn't figured
out way to put a math number to it yet
but i just gave it to you data says
don't do it
this is the ramsay show